à croire que la mort est injuste est-ce
que les miracles existent vraiment c'est
l'une des questions que pose le film
miraculeux un écrasement d'avion sert de
pivot dans cette complexe histoire où de
nombreux personnages se croisent sans
toutefois se rencontrer ce film choral
met en vedette une impressionnante
distribution
xavier dolan en témoins de jéhovah anne
dorval en fabrique aussi robin aubert ou
en accros du jeu alors que louise turcot
et julien poulin joue les nouveaux
amoureux
c'est le 4e film de podz daniel grou de
son vrai nom
les attentes sont grandes puisque le
réalisateur québécois cumule les succès
à la télé 19 2 c à son premier film les
7 jours du talion a été présenté au
festival de sundance ont suivi le
percutant 10 et demi et la sphère du
monde
tiré d'une histoire vécue chez toi parce
que votre cube puis ça n'existe pas
miraculé homme s'inscrit dans la
continuité de la filmographie de potes
un drame sombre qui nous plonge dans les
tourments de l'humain montrant du doigt
ses travers et ses vices mais aussi sa
fragilité
que japonais l'acteur gabriel sabourin
un signe ici son premier scénario en
solo des destins croisés qui ne trouvent
leur sens qu'à la conclusion le suspense
est soutenu mais certains détours sont
un peu lourd et parfois moralisateur
miraculeux homme ne connaîtra
probablement pas le succès populaire de
19,2 mais les cinéphiles apprécieront
l'évolution de ce cinéaste québécois ici
tanya lapointe radio canada montréal